what's up
guys lunch money time bang bang
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
pelina evilova marinova pompliano
p-i-m-p
you all already know she's looking like
a lumberjack she is ready to chop
some wood for the record the lumberjacks
do this
no i'm tired of the studio we're done
with the studio
we're not doing the studio anymore maybe
we'll go back to the studio but for
right now
we're doing it from the couch that's
right not the kitchen but the couch
that's what we're gonna do from now on
uh before i forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
go and earn up to eight point six
percent apy
in an interest-bearing account your bank
pays you 0.03 to 0.05 percent
on your deposit you can go and deposit
digital dollars
in a blockfy account go to
blockfy.comlunchmoney
and you can earn up to eight point six
percent it
is awesome i'm an investor in the
company i'm a user of the product
and i am very very happy he's very happy
what's up do we like the couch better i
think so
yeah it just feels more us it does
all of our friends by the way they
appreciate all of your comments from
friday they had a blast
maybe they'll be back another time okay
great sure okay
because i don't think people can hear me
the economic uncertainty brought on by
the coronavirus has spared
no generation of american workers but a
recent survey found that
young professionals could be bearing the
brunt of the financial stress
uh 85 percent of young americans are
reporting they feel pushed to the limit
in at least one area when it comes to
their jobs managing their finances
studying
or social media what okay about one in
three young americans reported that they
had been laid off
or put on temporary leave td ameritrade
found
the numbers are particularly stark for
members of gen z
ages 15 to 22 who are almost three times
more likely to be laid off than their
older
counterparts well the young people
worked in the service industry that's
exactly what this
is they're waiters they're waitresses
they work at all sorts of hospitality
like those businesses have been
decimated they've had the most layoffs
and so if young people work those jobs
of course young people have been laid
off more
makes sense right but do we think that
this is kind of
like if i'm graduating from college now
it's harder to get a job people aren't
hiring other people are being laid off
like what do we think is uh the
potential for my
career here well there are very few
people who end up staying
in the waitress job waiter job and like
the service industry
usually that is a stepping stone it's
like kind of a first job and they go on
and get other jobs whether that is
to become accountants or you know
whatever um
but what ends up occurring is there's
turnover so
when you're you know take me for example
when i was like 16 17 years old i worked
at chick-fil-a and at subway
right eventually i moved on to other
things and some other
young kid took my spot right so i don't
think this is limited to the service
industry i think you're saying that the
majority of young people
are in the service industry but i don't
i don't think that's all i think that
there is a
disproportionate number of people who've
been laid off that are from the service
industry and that's why young people
have been hurt so badly
if you think about uh there's pretty
much
out of all of the industries the service
industry specifically
is going to be responsible for uh on a
percentage basis i bet you majority of
the service industry in america got laid
off
so here's my here's my question for you
you know how 0809 kind of put
kind of psychologically scarred a lot of
young people seeing their families go
through that and lose all their
money yeah uh do we think this will have
a similar effect
on gen z as millennials went through
0-809
uh it's different i think this time
because in a lot of cases
it's them being affected rather than in
a way though now with the housing crisis
it was their parents being affected yeah
now it's them being affected so they're
the ones who have lost their jobs like
all that kind of stuff
uh remember the people who usually have
accumulated assets
right or older because they've had more
time to build wealth and accumulate
those assets
those people end up actually doing
pretty well right now
housing prices are up stocks are uh like
the older people
in some cases are doing better than the
younger people which is very weird
yeah right all right what's next so
remember
elon musk revealing his neural link
thing on friday or thursday so neurolink
is the
brain computer interface okay so he
revealed it
on friday a working brain computer
interface capable of processing
real-time information from the brain of
a living pig
now this is nothing new because we've
done this with humans we've put
chips in their brains and kind of
analyzed the neurons or whatever for
medical reasons but basically
he in the short term his company hopes
to create early warning systems for
heart attacks and strokes
with a grand vision of curing
neurological disorders and even
achieving
seamless two-way communication between
human brains and computers
yeah it's a no-brainer would you get the
chip
just as a regular human without a
neurological disorder yeah
no oh i would get it for sure i'm i'm
fascinated by the idea of intelligence
augmentation
the idea that like rather than me say oh
i can't remember that thing or i don't
know what the
number is or something and then going to
google and searching imagine if you had
the power of a computer
up here yeah but then you get into then
you get into the whole like
people with money will become super
humans and people without money will be
regular humans there's there's a lot of
ethical things to think about and
but that none of that has to do with
whether i'm putting it in my head or not
if i got if it's safe
and i got access to a computer in my
brain
now i don't have to respond and say oh i
read it on the computer instead i could
just say i got a computer in my brain
well i hope you're ready to be wrong
because everything you remember is wrong
when i talk so then the computer will
actually take meticulous notes for you
of course you cannot forget then i would
have a perfect memory if i had a
computer in my brain
so you're in for me to get it no okay
tick tock and i could speak and i could
speak perfect bulgarian to your family
great tick tock has chosen a bitter for
its u.s new zealand
and australian businesses and it could
announce the deal as soon as
tomorrow microsoft in partnership with
walmart and oracle are the two top
contenders the sale price is expected to
be in the range of
20 to 30 billion dollars this is a
misleading sentence
it's microsoft and walmart are a partner
and then
oracle is a misleading sentence it's
just
there's a comma and i can't tell you the
comma
okay a comma is to pause no it's to put
the two things together okay
but microsoft and walmart or oracle who
do you think is the winner
i believe they'll go with microsoft and
uh walmart
maybe you think oracle i think that
if i had to choose between these two i
would choose microsoft over oracle
but i think that it could be a dark
horse
who oracle no one that's not listed here
could be the trailer no i don't think
trolling because
uh by dance and tick tock came out and
said triller is not a contender that
that's the competitor to uh yeah i i
tend to think that it's somebody that
hasn't been mentioned yet it's
it's kind of like when dara got hired at
uber there was all this speculation
about all these other people who were
gonna be the ceo of uber
and then out of nowhere dara came i was
like what do you think the dark horse
would be
what i don't want to say what facebook
they have the money they're notorious
for making
huge acquisitions bet the company style
and
three is uh if anyone is going to
be able to take something like this and
put the gas on it and use all of their
data science and computer science and
everything
facebook i'm not saying that they're
going to be the one but i am saying that
nobody's talking about facebook and it
wouldn't surprise me
if they had a shot at it so there was a
dark horse that would be my pick
i okay do we agree
we'll see we don't disagree we don't
disagree okay that's fine i'll take that
what's next
so a happiness museum has opened in
copenhagen denmark and the idea is to
show why certain countries are happier
than others by the way guys
i have a book recommendation for you the
geography of bliss
read it it's great this man goes all
over the world to figure out like why
certain countries are happier it's very
interesting and it's also funny
so here's the one thing i found
interesting in this museum ready
so trust toward fellow citizens and
political institutions
is a major factor in global happiness
and in a time where i feel like people
have lost all sense of trust
in our institutions but at the same time
i think we've
gained trust in individual people yeah
but you have to remember that
of course how much you trust an
institution is going to lead to your
happiness right
because because it's just the more you
have distrust the more on guard you are
the more you feel like you're always
getting screwed or getting lied to or
whatever
like like you just you're unsettled but
if you just have
trust like i trust pelena then you're
always happy because you don't have to
like constantly question everything and
worry about things and all that
okay but in a time where everybody's
questioning our political institutions
the banks like financial institutions
everything
how can we be happy you find something
else to trust
well you either find something else to
trust or two is you just are at peace
with that like
take me for example i never felt like
i trusted the institutions anyways right
so it's just like
it's not like i've lost trust i was just
always comfortable with like of course
that's not true
right and so i don't look at them as
the source of truth and now i'm
distrusting so like the move
from i used to trust you now i don't is
very unsettling it causes chaos
uncertainty all that kind of stuff
but if you're coming at it from i've
never trusted you yeah i've never
trusted you then of course
now that other people are finding it out
you're almost like what are you guys do
you trust bitcoin
no that's the beauty is you don't have
to trust it you can verify the
information
right it's fully transparent you can go
verify
don't trust verify that's the number as
a journalist
that's how people do it don't trust
verify
uh most journalists today okay
may not do that we'll just leave it at
that a lot of people are skeptical
therefore they go and investigate and
verify
um okay but it's cool because so in the
museum
people left so like the museum
organizers left a full wallet with
a bunch of money in it and museum staff
have periodically placed this wallet on
the floor for more than a month and it's
been returned to reception with all the
items inside
every single time that means that people
have trust in other humans
i don't get that what do you mean it's
fine okay whatever
if you find 20 on the floor uh if on
you're on the street of new york and
there's 20
on the side so i actually that happened
to me one time and you picked it up
no so well i'll tell you right now so i
was um
i was going to jury duty and there was a
20 bill
on the floor in front of the building
and i saw it
and i was like ah so i picked it up and
i went and gave it to
the person who had just passed but i
thought they uh lost it
and they're like no no that's not mine i
was like well here's 20 bucks
i didn't take it okay so
who is this person what do you mean i
okay so she stole from somebody and gave
it to somebody else
it was on the floor nobody no you stole
money from somebody
you don't know who the owner was well
they weren't there so
how do you know oh my god you're so
annoying
um all right what's next hong kong
that's
okay stop that's not that's not what i
wanted to talk about plan has made a
mistake
hold on hold on guys hold on she has
made a mistake
oh shoot she has made a mistake so
basically bill gates
so okay warren buffett turned 90. bill
gates
gave him a hilarious gift which was he
did like a martha stewart style video in
which he's baking an oreo cake
and the whole joke is that um is that
uh warren buffett once ate
an oreo cake for breakfast he he's
notorious for eating bad foods
um yeah his favorite dessert for
breakfast is oreos
it's a good breakfast i have a friend
actually this weekend who was eating a
lot of oreos
so so gates said one thing that was
surprising to learn about warren is that
he basically stuck to eating what he
liked when he was six years old
i remember one of the first times he
stayed at our house and he opened up a
package of oreo steep for breakfast
our kids immediately demanded they have
some too he may set a poor example for
young
people but it's a diet that somehow
works from him
he eats mcdonald's he drinks coca-cola
hey whatever
and he invests in those companies
because he likes them right it's pretty
good
speaking of mcdonald's okay this one is
wild guys
okay so this woman put burger and fries
in its original
packaging from mcdonald's in her closet
in 1996
and the 24 year old year old hamburger
and fries
have never rotted or decayed they look
like they are in perfect condition
think about eating that no yeah for real
it went viral on tick tock she kept
an uneaten mcdonald's burger for over
two decades
nothing has happened think about eating
that and what it does to your insides
all the preservatives all that stuff
i just don't believe it the woman has
kept everything intact from the original
paperbacks the paper wrapping
i bet you mcdonald's could verify that's
original
scam alert no mold on it at all
scam alert i don't know this is a
classic
example of we're going to read in two
weeks uh
it was faked see no trust zero trust
because it it defies science it does not
what if all this see this is the this is
the difference they pumped into it
i really believe it could happen still
wouldn't
okay let's go buy it we'll go do an
experiment we'll buy a hamburger we'll
leave it for a week and then we'll see
what you think
okay i'm not gonna eat it i just wanna
observe it no
literally we're going to buy a hamburger
and we're going to sit it
and in a closet and we'll see what
happens and when you have to deal with
the ants
that have got where are the ants going
to come from
we live in a building well everyone
lives at a building
that's how that's how a roof gets over
your head no it's gonna take them
forever
to get up here okay are you ready
all right are you ready literally
somebody could be like oh look at this
rock i found this rock
is from mars and plenty of like oh they
found the rock on mars they told me that
there was something
i trust in my fellow human beings
okay hold on i like the couch better by
the way guys the couch is way better
than the studio yeah but i think
the background's a little bright that's
fine leave a comment if you like the
studio
or the uh the couch baby you can hear me
properly i'm
yelling guys i'm yelling can you hear me
yelling
what's the next topic it's a joke
you ready yes why are ghosts terrible
liars
why are ghosts terrible liars yeah
because they can't be seen because you
can see right through them
it's almost like i wrote the jokes
myself there ladies and gentlemen
that was a that would be a funny one if
it was funny
is he you're allowing it was funny no
i'm laughing at my own joke
all right guys that's it for lunch
monday today while washers trying to get
rich rest of us just trying to get our
lunch money right
go out do some kind things for people
today and we'll talk to you
tomorrow be kind to your friends
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what
you're a bigger fan of block fight than
you are of me block flies my second
favorite thing in the world behind
polena
they've got three products they can give
you a us dollar loan
you can earn up to 8.6 interest on an
interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point percent is
pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends